[Musik]
ich wusste nichts von ihm ich wusste nur
dass er also recht gut geige spielte
ich weiß dass er bei seiner großmutter
wohnte
und ich erfuhr auch noch dass er vorher
mal irgendwann im weißen haus gewesen
ist
und willi machte einen völlig normalen
eindruck und ich hatte bei ihm nie in
der ersten seiten das gefühl dass um ihn
etwas besonderes war
[Musik]
ich wusste schon dass sein vater ein
vietnamesischer soldat der französischen
haben mich war das wusste ich schon aber
das wurde so hingenommen wie das hat
eben ist er war ein uneheliches kind und
gab es einige von dass er natürlich
irgend etwas geahnt hat man hat ja immer
gesagt die und diese sterilisierungen
wurden ja vorgenommen unter dem unter
der rubrik eine irgendeiner untersuchung
ist ob er es sich niemals das weiß ich
er hat sich nie darüber geäußert und
solange ich ihn kannte wusste ich das
nicht ich sehe noch freudestrahlend wie
er den musterungsbescheid also in der
intelligenten hielt ich werde die muster
und da hatte er es geschafft
man sieht an den bildern dass er es
geschafft hatte
aber eben nach der ausbildung nur 14
tage sagt dabei er tot
[Musik]
willibert geboren 1923 in euskirchen
gestorben 1944 als soldat der wehrmacht
irgendwo in norditalien von willi bad
ist nicht sehr viel mehr geblieben als
verblassen der erinnerungen eine
handvoll fotos ein paar wenige dürre
lebensdaten das war gewollt so denn der
deutsche staat hatte beschlossen dass
menschen wie willi bad keine nachkommen
haben dürfen
mit ihm sollte auch das gedächtnis an
ihn und seine schicksalsgenossen
verschwinden im sommer 1937 wurde er
zwangssterilisiert da war er noch nicht
einmal 14 jahre alt willi war eins von
mehreren hundert kindern mit einer
deutschen mutter und einen vater der ein
soldat aus den französischen kolonien
war
am 28 juni 1919 empfangen die
siegermächte im schloss von versailles
eine kleine gesellschaft des deutschen
reichs vor allem die französische
regierung unter georges clemenceau zeigt
sich unnachgiebig von deutschem boden
soll nie wieder gefahr für frankreich
ausgehen
im januar 1920 brücken alliierte
truppenverbände in die linksrheinischen
gebiete von kiel bis köln ein von den
100.000 soldaten der französischen
besatzungsarmee stand rund ein fünftel
aus französischen kolonie aus algerien
marokko tunesien aus dem senegal aus
madagaskar oder vietnam
im märz 1920 versuchen angehörige der
sogenannten reichswehr unter führung von
general von lüttwitz die demokratisch
gewählte regierung von reichskanzler
gustav bauer zu stürzen
der aufstand der putschisten scheitert
aber als reaktion darauf besetzen
französische soldaten nun auch städte
rechts des rheins am 6 april 1920 ziehen
marokkanische regimenter in frankfurt am
main ein
es kommt zu zusammenstößen mit
demonstranten
die marokkaner schießen es gibt tote und
verletzte
der vorfall von frankfurt wird zum
willkommenen anlass den volkszorn gegen
die französischen besatzer insgesamt zu
schüren
und so wird von nationalisten der
faschisten und rassisten ab dem frühjahr
1920 eine kampagne gegen die so genannte
schwarze schmach orchestriert die mit
allen verfügbaren mitteln der propaganda
und desinformationen arbeitet in dieser
kampagne gibt es keine unschuldigen
parolen und keine unschuld der bilder
wenn wir sie hier dennoch zeigen dann
aus einem einzigen grund das echo dieser
100 jahre alten kampagne wirkt auf uns
seltsam vertraut sie beginnt mit
meldungen wie diesen am sonntag den 17
dezember 1919 gegen vier uhr nachmittags
über viele ein farbiger französischer
kolonialstadt die 16-jährige
fabrikarbeiterin gertrud m aus
euskirchen als diese über den bahndamm
der eisenbahnstrecke düren euskirchen
nach hause ging
der soldat fasste das erschreckte
mädchen bei den händen war was in den
graben und hielt ihm den mund zu um es
am schreien zu am sonntag den 11
september 1921 lockte ein farbiger
französische soldat der besatzung in
euskirchen die neunjährige josef kann
sich indem er süßigkeiten anbot ganz
verschwörer 1920 wurde der elfjährige
albert w aus schnaittach ins krankenhaus
als geschlechtskrankheit geliefert wie
die ermittlungen ergaben rührte die
krankheit daher dass der knabe etwa drei
monate vorher von einem marokkanischen
soldaten in wieder natürlicherweise
gebraucht worden war
bis auf die knochen durch das blut so
kehraus im frühjahr 1920 scheint es als
habe sich über nacht ein heer von
afrikanischen vergewaltigen und
päderasten auf den weg gemacht um
deutsche frauen mädchen und knaben
systematisch zu schänden und zu entehren
die empörung über das vermeintlich
barbarische verhalten der französischen
kolonie soldaten auf deutschem boden
treibt bizarre blüten
hier sehen wir einen schwarzen mit
deformierten lippen der beinahe wie ein
affe aussieht unter dem französischen
films und wenn man die münze umdreht
sieht man die deutsche frau die an einen
marterpfahl gefesselt ist und das ist
dirigierte penis eines schwarzen mannes
gekrönt von einem militär helm das sind
die sexuellen obsessionen der schwarze
schmach kampagne
dieses stück ist ein typisches beispiel
für die propaganda schwarzen schmach die
sehr vielfältig ist
wir können uns heute nicht vorstellen
wie mächtig diese propaganda ist denn es
wurde enorm viel geld investiert es gibt
broschüren die ins englische ins
niederländische schwedische französische
spanische us-amerikanische und so weiter
übersetzt wurden
es gibt postkarten illustrationen
plakate medaillen theaterstücke und es
werden filme zu diesem thema gedreht
[Musik]
wenn wir über die rolle von frauen und
frauenkörpern in der kampagne gedanken
machen denn es ist wichtig zu verstehen
dass die meisten frauen nicht wirkliche
opfer von männern schwarzen männern
kolonial soldaten waren aber sie wurden
bewusst zu opfern gemacht von den
trägern der kampagne und in vielen
fällen von männern
das waren weiße europäische männer das
waren autoren von broschüren das wasser
von novellen roman die frauen in ihren
eigenen männerfantasien brachialen
brutalen animalis tischen sexuellen
trieben aussetzen aber das war nicht die
triebe von diesen schwarzen soldaten
sondern das waren gewalttätige sexuelle
fantasien von männern die sich diese
geschichten ausdachte
es gab vereinzelte übergriffe auch
übergriffe von konya soldaten
aber diese waren kein schwarzes problem
oder kein problem von kolonialtruppen
das wurde aber so dargestellt
schwarze schmach war in den köpfen
vieler europäer bevor der erste kolonie
soldat an fuß in das rheinland gesetzt
hat die idee das schwarze männer
gefährlich sind für weiße frauen dass
sie sexuell triebhafte sind dass sie
diese triebe nicht unter kontrolle haben
dass sie einer primitiven rasse
angehören
diese ideen sind weitverbreitet common
sense
[Musik]
protest gegen die anwesenheit der
kolonial soldaten auf deutschem boden
kommt längst nicht nur aus völkischen
und nationalistischen kreisen
er wird auch von hochrangigen vertretern
der politik gestützt
wir können es nicht verstehen wie die
kulturwelt schweigen kann zu diesem uns
aufgezwungenen schmutz wie sie schweigen
kann zu den vielen sittlichkeit
verbrechen der versorgung der
bevölkerung durch geschlechtskrankheiten
und anderes mehr
dass die verwendung farbiger truppen
niederste kultur als aufseher über eine
bevölkerung von der hohen geistigen und
wirtschaftlichen bedeutung der
rheinländer eine herausfordernde
verletzung der gesetze europäischer
zivilisation ist sei auch hier erneut in
die welt hinaus gerufen
friedrich ebert reichspräsident also die
kampagne kann ja aus zweierlei
perspektive betrachten das ist zum einen
die staatlich gelenkte
propagandakampagne das ist ein versuch
diverser friedensbedingungen zu kippen
einfluss zu nehmen auf die weiteren
nachkriegs bedingungen
es ist ein versuch internationale
solidarität mit deutschland wieder
herzustellen deutschland ist nicht im
völkerbund zu diesem zeitpunkt das ist
das eine das wäre so eine klassische
politik historische betrachtungsweise
und das was sie jetzt ja ansprechen er
ist warum verfängt diese kampagne bei so
vielen anderen leuten die
kriegsniederlage wird als versagen der
militärischen führung der monarchie aber
eben auch der deutschen soldaten
interpretiert nicht offen
diese niederlage wird in dieser
schwarzen schwach kampagne nicht
eingestanden sondern die ursachen für
die niederlage
die wird auf die teilnahme der
afrikanischen soldaten transferiert also
wenn sie so wollen eine klassische
übertragungs situation
es ist im sinne der kampagnen führer
dass die meldungen über massenhafte
vergewaltigungen deutscher frauen auch
im ausland beachtung finden
wenige tage nach den zusammenstößen von
frankfurt erscheint im april 1920 in
england einen artikel in dem die
anwesenheit französischer
kolonialtruppen auf deutschem boden
angeprangert wird
verfasser ist der englische journalist
und labour abgeordnete ed mondini moral
[Musik]
der artikel ist vom zehnten april und
erspart ihr black sketchen europe's
action horror let loose in fans online
disappearance of young german geholt
[Musik]
moral verurteilt in diesem artikel die
französische besatzung am rhein und ihre
verwendung von schwarzen truppen
beschreibt dieses als ein horror ja als
einen eine furchtbare situation
er ist schon von anfang an in kontakt
mit deutschen deutschen offiziellen
stellen und erhält informationen
betrifft die beeinflussung der
öffentlichen meinung in england
hinsichtlich der belegung des
rheinlandes mit schwarzem truppen eine
reihe englische politiker und
publizisten die sich im lauf der letzten
monate in berlin aufhielten wurde
zahlreiches material über das verhalten
der schwarzen truppen im besetzten
gebiet zugängig gemacht
morell hat das ihm übergebene material
zur abfassung einer broschüre der horror
und rein benutzt die überaus
wirkungsvoll geschrieben ist
es war ganz offenbar dass der horror ein
bei jedermann ein gefühl physischen und
geistigen ekels hervorbrachte
das auswärtige amt es hinter den
kulissen immer auch mit dabei also
ausländische besucher einzuladen die
dann ins rheinland kommen und die dann
zurückgehen in ihr heimatland und
berichten wie furchtbar die dinge stehen
zu den von der deutschen regierung
umworbenen ausländischen unterstützern
der kampagne gehört auch die
amerikanerin rey bereits der weißen
amerikanischen oberschicht aufgewachsen
wird beverage zu einer der aggressivsten
agitator innen gegen die so genannte
schwarze schwach haben die leitenden
männer aller länder den verstand
verloren denn blindlings stürzen sie
unsere weiße rasse unsere weißen frauen
in den abgrund
ich appelliere an alle frauen der welt
ich appelliere an alle männer dieses
namens noch wert sind helft weiße frauen
weiße mädchen weiße knaben sind täglich
stündlich in gefahr und diese gefahr
wird bestehen solange ein schwarzer
berechtigt ist macht über weiter
auszuüben in amerika hankmann einen
schwarzen auf der sich an einer weißen
frau vergreift vorstellung wurden
geteilt und kam aus der mitte der
internationalen europäischen
wissenschaft man vor zu kongressen da
haben sich schwedische deutsche
italienische französische britische
wissenschaftler auf kongressen getroffen
um diese fragen zu diskutieren und die
bevölkerung in europa hatte auch ein
bewusstsein dass es wichtig war weiß zu
sein und weiß zu bleiben eine der
wenigen die in deutschland ihre stimme
gegen die rassistischen parolen der
schwarze schmach kampagne erheben ist
luise z
sie ist bereits mitte 50 als sie 1919
als abgeordnete für die us pd in die
nationalversammlung einziehen
im mai 1920 hält sie im reichstag eine
historische rede ich will darauf
hinweisen dass diejenigen die sich jetzt
mit recht gegen die fischen reiten im
besetzten gebiet wänden kein wort des
protestes gefunden haben als in
deutschland unsere eigenen landsknechte
so viele hoheiten und brutalitäten gegen
deutsche frauen begangen haben
ich verweise ferne darauf dass unsere
truppen im ausland in frankreich in
belgien in russland in der furchtbarsten
weise gehaust haben und gerade auf dem
gebiet der sittlichkeit
wie in dieser weise der rassenhass
geschürt wird dass man sagt es ist eine
provokation für deutschland und für ganz
europa es ist eine schändung europa sven
schwarze truppen in das herz europas in
deutschland hinein gelegt werden was ist
das denn anderes als dass man sich gegen
die schwarze rasse wendet
es ist kaum zu verstehen dass luise
zieht diese große sozialdemokratische
politikerin heute beinahe vergessen ist
[Musik]
wir deutsche haben behaftet unsere
kultur schon genug geschändet durch den
rassenhass der bei uns wuchert die
deutschnationalen versammlungen werden
ja gar nicht mehr anders abgehalten als
mit dem ruf nieder mit den juden juden
raus dieser rassenhass ist ein
kennzeichen tiefster kultur schander
eines können nationalisten revanchisten
rassisten schon 1920 nicht verhindern
die menschen am rhein finden zueinander
männer aus afrika von den philippinen
und aus vietnam und frauen aus
deutschland ein lied maria heute
nachmittag ich erhalten denn schön
adresse in brief von ali die maria jetzt
sich besser aber ich weiß nicht wie viel
tag bleiben hier aber nicht lange mein
herz frauen
darum ich nicht gesehen montag
glauben du bleiben teufel mich weil ich
viel liebe für dich bitte schön war ja
schicken nicht ein fotografie
ich hab ihr freund gesehen ein schiller
angesicht bitte schön wenn er schreibt
mir schnell ein brief
schließen meint brief mit tausende grüße
und küsse und etzella in den deutschen
reihen gebieten werden zwischen 1919 und
1928 einige hundert kinder geboren die
aus beziehungen zwischen deutschen
frauen und kolonial soldaten stammen
ihre genaue zahl ist nicht bekannt sie
reicht von etwa 400 bis an die 1000
diese kinder ihre mütter und deren
familien trifft von anfang an der
bannstrahl sozialer ächtung
[Musik]
leider hat ein teil der weiblichen
bevölkerung ihre sittliche und standes
ehre sowie ihre nationale würde nicht zu
wahren gewusst und in anstoß erregender
weise mit den soldaten der
besatzungstruppen verkehr unterhalten
dieser verkehr ist selbstverständlich in
vielen fällen nicht ohne folgen
geblieben sitzler regierungsrat sollen
wir schweigend dulden dass künftig an
den ufern des rheins statt der
heldenlieder weißer schön gewichtiger
gut gewachsener geistig hochstehender
regsam gesunder deutscher die
krächzenden laute geräusch eckiger
nieder stürmischer breit neunziger
plumper halb tierischer so vieli tischer
mulatten ertönen rosenberger arzt
[Musik]
wenn man von moratti sierung redet setzt
das voraus dass es auch sehr viele
rheinische frauen geben muss die
freiwillig mit mit kolonial soldaten
verkehren und auch kinder haben und es
wird auch von vielen nationalistischen
propagandisten kampagne gemacht gegen
die sogenannte weiße schwach und das ist
eine logistische eine frauenfeindliche
variante die eben sagt schlimm genug
dass die franzosen uns diese schwarzen
soldaten ins land bringen aber jetzt
haben wir auch noch all diese deutschen
frauen die keinen ehrgefühl haben und
kein patriotisches gefühl und die
reihenweise massenweise mit diesen
kolonial soldaten sexuelle beziehungen
haben
die exklusion die dort angesprochen ist
der weißen frau aus dem kollektiv der
deutschen nation ist natürlich eine
rassistische die vorstellung ist dass
der deutsche volkskörper sich aus sich
selbst generiert und dass alle anderen
die im sinne der rassisten rassenschande
begehen
aus diesem volkskörper ausgeschlossen
werden müssen
und da ist natürlich die annahme wenn
jemand eine dunklere hautfarbe hat kann
der der oder er oder sie eben nicht
wirklich deutscher sein dass das da
sieht man schon tief sitzen das
verständnis deutschland heißt bestimmte
ethnische identität deutsch ist wer die
richtige hautfarbe hat aber was ist mit
jenen denen man den afrikanischen oder
asiatischen vater auf den ersten blick
nicht ansieht wie zum beispiel willi
barth aus euskirchen der eindruck seiner
fremdartigkeit die variable rein
abstrakte im grunde genommen er sprach
eine derart breiten rebellischen dialekt
nun also dass er so wie gesagt also es
gab keinen in euskirchen den mann von
der sprache her eindeutiger ja von
seiner herkunft fährt definieren konnten
weil sie sprache definierte ihn als
einen uhr alteingesessenen und das war
für uns immer entscheiden
[Musik]